to P the wings and bodies of our God for
stud so hello everyone I'm here with
Richard Roland and Neil degrade as you
know we are coming up on the symbolic
World Summit the very first time we're
going to do something with all of us
live in person and so I thought it would
be a great idea to have two of the
speakers two of my precious uh let's say
collaborators for the last few years
with me here
I have to say I'm excited even just
because it's actually the first time
that I'll meet Richard Roland in person
you know he he has been on my channel
for years now was it like two years
almost a little over two years yeah
little over two years with and I've
never met him I'm getting ready because
he's 6'4 and he does jiujitsu so I'm
getting ready for that experience like
I'm gonna hip toss you as soon as I see
right away he'll just right into the
ground yeah you're a security plan
you're the entire security detail for
the conference as well Richard so yeah
got that going for you well I'm really
looking forward to getting to meet both
of you in person I uh in fact earlier
today Neil I Darkhorse has just become
my my writing album I listen to it like
basically every day now while I'm trying
to get my writing in each morning so I'm
really looking forward to meeting you
and and your wife and obviously Jonathan
you've been living basically rentree in
my house for the last several years so
uh this is going to be awesome awesome
it's going to be great so what we're
going to do with you is we're going to
give you a sense of what's going to
happen at the conference everything is
set up the schedule is now available and
so we can kind of look at how it's going
to work for people that are going to
come and so I'm going to share my screen
and so welcome to the symbolic World
Summit and so the the way it's going to
work is when you come to the summit you
will be on different paths and so we
have three different paths we have a
path with it which is related to art
logocentric
art um that's the one that I'm mostly
going to be involved with there is a
universal history path which Richard is
going to be on with Father Steven D
young who will be speaking on his own
but will also be part of that path and
then we have the Hearth and Hospitality
path which will be about how to kind of
integrate um integrate symbolism into
your everyday life and so for the
logocentric art one obviously it's going
to be the best one I'm just saying you
know
because yeah so uh let me jump in
Jonathan um go for it Neil my
understanding of how this is going to
work with the schedule is that day one
we get there day one is it's mostly the
evening it's a registration it's getting
to meet people that you've known online
uh you know meet people within the S
symbolic world who have the same
interests as you but on day two is when
the paths begin so around uh I think
it's around 10 o'c we break we break
apart into these two different paths now
so for everybody come to the conference
they have to choose a path each day so
logo Centric art uh for example is going
to have is going to be uh mainly for
myth makers and Artisans but also people
who want to get better at breaking down
the symbolic meaning within stories
thems and in literature I think that'll
be a really helpful path for them at the
same time competing with us head-to-head
in the Octagon is uh Richard Roland and
uh Richard sorry I pluralized your name
like everyone does to you um Richard and
uh father Stephen are going to be going
head-to-head against us so we're we're
basically try to get people to sign up
uh for this ahead of time so that we
know which group is going to be in which
room because one of the rooms is
slightly larger than the other I gotta
warn you because father Steph and I
together are a formidable team the
tallest I think he's like six seven so
no he's he's a I think he's about as
tall as I am but he's he's uh he's he's
very big I like to exaggerate I like to
give him Nephilim type he's at least 6
foot n that's true yeah okay great great
so someone asked me on Twitter if we
could make uh some of the Giants in
God's dog look like Father Steven young
I'm just saying that would be
amazing great so uh yeah there's a path
you have to choose ahead of time on uh
you'll get an email about this if you've
bought a conference ticket uh and on day
three it's just one single breakout for
the day and so you'll get to um the
there'll be a second part of the logo
Centric art and that'll be with vasper
Stamper and Martin Shaw quite another
Power Team and then competing against
them going head to-head in the Hearth
and hospitality is Nicholas kotar he's
probably going to tell you more about
how to survive a Russian fairy tale I'm
sure Baba Yaga and some of those people
will come into His talk uh if he gives a
similar talk to the one he gave uh when
I was in the keys with him recently it
was uh it was Stellar I'm still chewing
on it so uh two months later as you can
see that there will be these PS on the
first day we will all be together uh we
are we are so fortunate to have John
Hees those who don't know him you've
probably seen him on the uh why are we
speaking about rabbits podcast that I've
been on I think all of you have been on
right yeah everybody here has on the
podcast and so he will be our uh our M
or Mater D he'll be how do you say that
in English he'll be like the host I
guess Master of Ceremonies Master of
Ceremonies that's the word be the Master
of Ceremonies for the the whole event um
the first evening will start with me
giving the first talk about
kind of this apocalyptic vision of the
world and how we can understand the
cosmos as Revelation trying to bring
together all the stuff that I've been
talking about for years into one talk so
I'm looking forward to that we'll have a
Q&A and then we are going to have a
concert which I hope you're practicing
Neil I hope you're practicing I'm always
practicing I'm finishing up the record
right now so the practicing begins soon
we've got the band together and uh we
are really excited to do this show we're
we're working on uh putting together a
light show right now which is kind of
fun to go with it I didn't know we we
would have that at our disposal but we
will uh hopefully some projection and
multimedia experience with dero Robins
so uh that's going to be great we're
going to play all of our biggest songs
the stuff you guys are familiar with and
a couple of songs you hadn't heard yet
because they will literally be coming
out that day also we're giving a free
digital download of the record to
everyone who comes to the conference
there'll be a little QR whatever they
call those QR codes is that what they're
called um it'll be a QR code you can
scan at our merch table and uh for
coming to the event you get a free
digital uh 24-bit version of the
record all right this is going to be
it's going to be amazing you haven't
performed in how long uh I perform we
perform all the time with different
things we haven't gotten the whole band
back together in quite a while so it was
uh yeah last decade uh before we did it
but I mean we sing and play all the time
I mean it's kind of unfair to say like
we haven't played we haven't played with
this particular line up in a while of
course of course yeah all right so day
two then is father Stephen is going to
present for the the in the morning and
his theme is just absolutely crazy
frederck n's Guide to the Bly
Resurrection he told me about this sorry
he told me a little bit about this when
we were at the Lord of spirits
conference together last year so I'm
very excited about this talk all right
this is going I'm happy that he's he's
preparing something amazing for us I'm
looking forward to it um and then this
is when we break up into the different
paths uh you know uh Neil the grade will
be there at the very F presenting the
very first one uh I will be in that path
as well go like you said going head toad
with Richard Roland now what's important
to understand in this breakdown is that
you will ultimately everybody will have
access to everything so if you come to
the conference you CH you choose a path
you get to see get to be part of that uh
conference part but everything will be
filmed so that at the end the
participants will get a way to access
all the all the talks uh so they could
rewatch them and they can also watch the
on that they missed and so we wanted to
make sure that everybody had access to
everything and then on the third day
again we have a breakout we have a panel
with everybody on the
stage uh when is when is Martin Shaw
doing his first talk Mark Shaw is on uh
yeah sorry go back to Friday afternoon
that's right on Friday at 3M is when
Martin Shaw is going to present riding
the back of a wolf myth making in the
time of the spy glass sounds amazing
Martin I I'm really looking forward to
that stuff man everybody's outdoing
themselves with their titles here I'm
just looking forward to being in the
same room with him like that's going to
be definitely
like it's a big deal I've admired his
work for a long time even before he
became a Christian so this is this is
pretty pretty insane no he's got an
energy to him there's something he's got
like a celebrity energy it's kind of
neat like if he's in the room it's like
you can people like are like who's that
guy even if they don't know him he's got
there's he's got a presence yeah
definitely I mean and he's such an
amazing Storyteller I can't I can't wait
he's going to tell part of what he's
going to do is going to be tell a story
he's going to have a speaking part but
he's also gonna have an actual Story
Part which is that's great when he tells
a story it's really wonderful um and
then we will finish with a last a last
little presentation for me kind of
trying to get a sense of what the future
is both in terms of what we're doing but
also just in terms of how I see what's
coming over the hill for for uh you know
for the whole story of Western
civilization and the story of of of
what's
coming that's it I mean yes it'll all be
super positive we'll end in a very
positive note U for sure and so this is
going to be I mean it's GNA be amazing I
i' I'm already seeing a lot of people
you know a lot of people are telling me
they're going to come you know that are
uh like it's hard because I can't I
don't want to say some of the people but
people that you've seen on the channel
you know different people that have been
around are going to be there and then
also people that wrote for the blog uh
people that are you know it's just going
to be all the people that you meet on
the Facebook that are really involved
and it's all it's going to be a real
life thing with real life people oh it's
gonna be like that scene in Bill and
teds too when they go to heaven and like
Einstein's playing cards with n or
something like that it's going to
there's going to be a lot of people
there that are going to surprise you who
are just Milling around um a couple
things worth mentioning that I was just
talking so Tyler from King 16 is putting
this all together for us and they have
there's a VIP key path and apparently
there's a there's 10 new VIP tickets
available they turned 10 normal tickets
into VIP tickets so if people were felt
like they missed out on the VIP you have
the chance to make that upgrade so the
VIP has a bunch of like they have their
own room uh they can hang out with
snacks and coffee and then you know the
speakers eventually will trickle in just
kind of like a uh you know you're at
Disney and you're doing a character meet
and greet we'll just wander in and take
pictures with you um so and then there's
also a meet and greet at the end and
there's some special stuff for the VIP
so if you want to get some extra time
with the speakers I think that's a great
um a really great path to do that also I
didn't see it on the schedule Jonathan
but on the final day we're in Tarpon
Springs Florida and St Nicholas uh
Cathedral is there it's a Orthodox
Cathedral it's a really wild building
and you're doing a tour with the VIPs at
8 AM that morning so they do a church
tour with you and that ends at 8:45 so
that's Saturday morning we'll have a
we'll have a church tour with the VIPs
yeah it's just hard to have we can't
have everybody in the church the same
time because we're looking at 500 people
so it's that doesn't seem reasonable to
detour so this is the best way we
thought would make sense to do a kind of
church tour hopefully we can film it too
I don't know we'll see if we can film it
that'd be nice too the church tour yeah
maybe I don't know yeah I got people
there with video that are coming with me
so sure uh let's say we're going to film
it and then uh other things that Tyler
wanted me to bring up um one uh anybody
you know there's still uh there's still
a bunch of tickets left uh regular
tickets left only a few VIP tickets but
if you're someone who wants to buy
tickets for someone I mean go for it
like if you if you're one of those
people like hey money is not an issue
buy everyone a ticket we want bring
bring people this is going to be an
incredible event to be at in person uh
but not just that um also consider if
you you've gotten an email from the
symbolic world you can email us and get
a um discount code if you want to get
tickets for five or more people like you
want to put together a group from your
church last minute I know a lot of you
people like me like anytime I go to a
conference I always buy my ticket last
minute and you're kind of in that zone
right now so now is the time if you want
to get them but yeah again there's a 10%
discount code for uh group buys of five
or more that people want to consider all
right so this is it folks I mean it's
coming it's going to come really fast
and it's going to be it's G to be so
much fun I'm really looking forward to
it to meeting you and then there'll be
people even uh I mean Heather pollington
who did Snow White she's coming in from
Europe you know Martin Shaw's coming
from England uh Andrew G's going to be
there just hanging out with us there'll
be a bunch of people that are just going
to be there hanging out that that you
will be surprised to see so looking
forward to that oh yeah and everybody's
super friendly I think again I can't
reiterate enough um we've gotten so
comfortable with this like engaging this
content um you know online but I mean we
were just all together you know Richard
didn't come but we went to London and
being together was just something else I
mean it I'm never around that many
people who I have so many things I want
to talk about and everything they talk
about is interesting to me and you know
because normally as I'm drifting through
life I start to talk about the things
I'm interested in and I just sound like
a crazy person to the person at the
coffee shop who who decided to strike up
a conversation with this guy with this
beard I thought they were going to be
able to give me their Christmas list but
instead they're talking about symbolism
and I I think it's a wild experience to
be uh to get together with that many
people that have so much in common I
think it's going to be incredible all
right folks so get your tickets if you
don't have them if you do have them
watch out for an email from the symbolic
world so that you can pick your path and
we can plan this out so we're all ready
to receive you at the end of February
and obviously pick my path uh because
it's going to be the best path uh we're
gonna get um we're gonna get some weird
stories about Genesis and uh I was
actually doing this with uh with Father
Steph's sort of blessing I feel I feel
like it's a little you know intimidating
to talk about the Bible with him in the
room but we we already kind of talked
about this last year and and I think
we're I think I think we're on the same
the same wavelength so uh it's going to
be it's going to be the best path choose
my path the best path I think I want one
of those Universal history Bingo cards
for the people in your room where like
every time you guys say like certain
things like Nephilim Tower of Babel they
check it off and then there can be some
kind of gift I think this is going to
happen this gon to be a lot of Tower of
Babble stuff in my in my talk I'm just
tell people now so for Jonathan it's
gonna be fractals chairs microphones
that's right the usual it'll be a good
time it'll be all right folks so this is
it we're gonna sign off and uh yeah
we're looking forward to seeing you
there in tarban Springs
byebye